what was the um for you how did how did
uh you and Dolph end up linking up like
and how did you end up signing and
because like were you always trying to
be a rapper or did it just kind of
happen like
uh but I ain't really
I ain't really like playing on it to go
like this this [ __ ] just religious
feelings in my hands hmm it was just
feelings in my hands it should feel
quick too like this should just
within like a
year or two span you should just fell
into my hand so you had no like you
weren't you weren't making records
or were you always kind of making songs
did you feel like it kind of just
happened quickly no in high school in
high school like my senior year that's
when I really just
got only this when I started putting
[ __ ] out like on YouTube and SoundCloud
and that is that that's how that's how I
create a buzz like within my city but
like I already had a name within like my
city
prior to like other than rapping like
you know what I'm saying like they just
knew me anyway but so senior year I mean
started rapping it just you know what
I'm saying just feel all into place yeah
and that's how uh when the dog Reach Out
I thought uh I got a lot I got locked up
by senior year
I think my senior year in high school
yeah no it was after I graduated yeah
well first of all shout out to you for
graduating yeah yeah I got out of there
yeah
not a lot of people uh get the diploma
so I'll salute to you yeah I got no
battery so he just reached out you got
locked up it was really my auntie uh is
married to his uncle like she just told
she's like just just talk to him I don't
really know exactly what she said but I
just know when I got out he had reached
out to me and boom we got in the car we
chopped it up and everything then it was
y'all were locked in yeah yeah we've
been locked in but it's like on the
music level basically yeah yeah on the
music though would you say that like he
he taught you
a lot about just recording or writing
records or like did he like because
Dolph has such a nice like I feel like
his hook games are just so underrated
like his really his hooks were crazy bro
really he just
he let everybody do them yeah you know
like him like try to like touch nobody
work or tell him matter how to do
nothing like he just you know what I'm
saying just did everybody beat him so
nah I ain't never
you never just suggest me nothing like
that yeah yeah